[SPARKS POPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: We can't all rub
shoulders with political greats
and movie stars, but for
the price of admission
to a wax attraction, anyone can
mingle with their wax replicas.
These look-alikes aren't
much for conversation,
but the likeness can be
startling, thanks to a process
honed over centuries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Famous faces come
to life in beeswax,
so it's almost like
seeing them in the flesh.
But how do they do it?
It often starts with
a face-to-face meeting
with the subject,
during which they take
more than 200 measurements
of the face alone,
and still more of the body.
Drawing on those
measurements and using photos
and additional research, an
artist sculpts a clay body
onto a metal skeleton.
This clay sculpture will
be used to make a mold.
The head, of course,
receives special attention.
They sculpt it in stages, and
this takes about six weeks.
To check the symmetry
of the sculptured face,
the artist stretches a wire
from the temple to the chin.
She measures it from
all angles and compares
the numbers to measurements
of the actual subject.
Every single aspect
of the clay face
must mirror that of the
subject's precisely,
so if it's even slightly
off, she makes adjustments.
Here, she redefines
the teeth a bit more,
and then she tweaks
the hairline.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They're now ready
for the next step,
the making of the head mold.
The worker paints plaster
onto the sculpture
in 14 different sections.
This multi-part mold can be
easily removed from the clay
head once the plaster dries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
After the clay head
has been discarded,
they give the reassembled
mold a quick rinse.
The wax artist turns the
plaster head mold upside down
and slots it into
the wax bench, so
named because it secures the
mold during the wax casting.
They melt blocks
of Japanese beeswax
and funnel the liquid wax into
the neck of the plaster cast.
They let it set for an hour,
just long enough for the wax
to solidify and
form a thick crust
around the inside of the cast.
The artist removes
crust at the neck
and pours out the
rest of the wax,
leaving a hollow
wax face inside.
They set it aside for another
hour to further solidify.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The wax artist
removes a plaster mold
and comes face to face
with the wax creation.
She examines it
thoroughly, confirming
that the detail from the
mold has been effectively
transferred to the wax and that
the wax face is a dead ringer
for the human subject.
The team then casts
the wax figure's hands,
and an artist
matches the subject's
skin tone against a chart.
She mixes paint and
dabs the brush in it.
She then strikes her
brush with another one,
so the paint splatters
across the hand.
She blots up the
paint to blend it in.
This technique gives
the wax a speckled look
that mimics human pores.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
She paints on knuckles, veins,
and distinctive markings
to mimic those on
the subject's hands.
She gives the nails a manicure
to make the hands look
identical to the subject's.
In the hands of
a skilled artist,
these wax hands
have come to life.
As a medical glass
eye spins, the artist
blots on a very wide pupil first
and then paints the periphery
to mimic the person's iris.
Iris color and pattern are
unique to the individual,
and the artist replicates
those qualities
as closely as possible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
She glues red silk threads
onto the whites of the eyes
to simulate broken
blood vessels.
It's another touch of realism.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They slot the eyes into
sockets in the wax head.
Then, the wax figure is ready
for its hair, actual human
hair matched to the subject's.
They pierce the wax
with a hot needle
to insert each
hair individually.
The wax melts and
closes around the hair.
This process can
take four weeks.
They also plug in
brows and lashes
and then brush on
paint like makeup.
With his face on, the wax
figure now looks true to life.
Once completed, wax figures
get movie-star treatment.
Their hair is washed
and styled regularly,
and their clothing is
routinely dry cleaned.
After all, even wax
versions of famous people
have to keep up appearances.
[MUSIC PLAYING]